you the mayor of oakland setting off a  firestorm on twitter after calling las  vegas a gross desert she made the  comment to a local news team when  talking about the oakland a's potential  move here to las vegas and why it's  difficult to build a new stadium there  because of sustainability issues now  others are firing back las vegas mayor  carolyn goodman agreed with mayor  schaff's comments about sustainability  and said that las vegas is a leader in  that sense and she invited the mayor on  a trip to las vegas saying the two could  go to a raider game  clark county commissioner michael naft  also had this to say on twitter calling  chefs comments ignorant and elitist  adding it may be one of the reasons  people companies and sports teams are  leaving oakland he also invited her to  come here to better inform her